[Applause]
thanks Jared's great to be back in New
York it's 11 years since I was last here
so it's been a while and we're going to
spend a little bit of time talking about
time series not very much about
forecasting although I will say a little
bit near the end well I'm going to talk
about forecasting competitions but not
so much about the forecasting of the
competitions so how many people have
heard of the in forecasting competition
just finished about a week ago it's the
fourth in a series of forecasting
competitions which have slowly got
bigger the M for competition had a
better I had exactly a hundred thousand
time series and you had to forecast all
of these series there was a competition
I'll tell you a little bit about the
results later the m3 competition was
actually held 20 years ago with three
thousand and three time series so I'm
going to start with that data set
because it was available to me when I
was preparing these slides so this was
came out of a paper in the International
Journal of forecasting which I happen to
be the editor-in-chief of that journal I
wasn't when this paper was published
written by spurious macro darkus and
Michelle ebon there they are both now
retired both good friends of mine and so
they they produce this forecasting
competition with three thousand three
time series people had to produce
forecasts of each series so I'm not
interested in that at the moment I just
want to look at the series if you've got
three thousand time series how do you
actually plot them playing one series is
fine plotting to in different colors is
not so bad I mean I'm using basic lots
so it's not quite as nice as ggplot but
still um but once you start getting a
few series together it just you really
can't do this can
okay Eddie's kind of um
the other one also has a red lot does
that matter okay so my point here is
that plotting time series like this is
not going to work went after you about
two or three so what are we going to do
so basically the idea is to go back to
one of my heroes in the statistical
world a guy called John Tukey who lives
not actually that far from here about
thirty five miles from here
and he was extremely famous in his day
and you use things he produced every
single day he coined the word software
and the word bits and the word byte and
he invented the boxplot so many things
that you everyone uses every day came
from Tookie so he's something of a hero
of mine he's also happens to be my PhD
supervisor supervisor supervisor
supervisor so he's sort of like my
great-great-great-grandfather although I
never met him he wrote a paper with his
fifth cousin Paul Tookie and introduced
the idea of what he called Cognos --tx
which we now call features take the data
set reduce them down to some summary
information and work with that rather
than with the original data so in the
case of time series you could compute
lag correlations you could compute
spectral entropy seasonality measures
things that tell you something about the
time series but not the data directly so
here's an example this is one of the
series in the m3 competition the data is
in the top panel the next three panels
contain components of the data we split
the data into pieces those pieces sum
together so the trend plus the season or
plus the remainder in the bottom three
panels add up to the data that's in the
top panel it's a very standard time
series decomposition so we can take that
done that decomposition and we can do
things with it we can say for example
look at the auto correlations of the
components and the remainder in
particular is interesting we can look at
how much variances in the remainder
compared to how much variances in the
rest of the series and that tells us
something about the
things like seasonality in the strength
of Trent we can compute spectral entropy
which is to do with how for castable or
how much signal that the data has if
it's has high spectral entropy then it's
basically noise if it has low spectral
entropy it's something that has a lot of
signal or not much noise and therefore
you we should be able to forecast it
well and we can look at transformations
of the data to see whether the variance
is changing with the level of the
spirits and so on so these are the sorts
of features I'm interested in computing
I have a package which is not on cran
called TS features which makes it easy
to compute these types of things so it's
on my github account I'll give you some
URLs in the last slide so we we load the
TS features package I'll load the tidy
verse as well because it makes some
things a little easier and then the
thing is features package you basically
give it a list of time series and
there's some functions and it for each
of those functions it computes the
features so that each function will
produce one or more features so it
applies to everything in the list so in
this particular example first of all I
define a new function so this section
here lambda STL is a function very short
function that just produces some
features of my data so it produces the
calculates those box-cox transformation
parameter that's optimal for this data
set and then it transforms the data and
which is here and then in this line
that's computing some features based on
an STL decomposition of the transform
data so you can imagine we can have lots
of these functions some of them are
built into the package this one is not
and then to compute the features we run
the TS features command so look the line
just here where my mouse is m3 data is a
list of time series so it's three
thousand and three long and every
element of that list is just at times it
was just a TS object and then we pass in
the second argument sum functions which
will compute things that we might be
interested in so in this case I'm asking
it to compute the frequency of the data
and the entropy of the data and then in
the next call I can I pass my new
function lambda STL and I have some
which come through the ellipses here the
dot dot dot so I'm gonna not have any
scaling and I produce some more features
so these two things are then bind
together using bind columns so I now
have a matrix which will be three
thousand and three long because that's
how many time series I've got and the
columns will be every feature that I've
computed on the data set and then I'm
selecting here some of those features
for later use so I'm just using the
Select function from deep liar sometimes
some of the features were missing for
example I asked for seasonal strength
with some of the data's annual so you
can't compute the seasonal strength
though it comes back as missing so I'm
replacing those missing values here with
zeros because if its annual data then it
doesn't have any seasonal strength then
I rename the features to make them a
little better for the graphing and I add
one more which is I take the frequency
which is one if its annual data for if
it's quarterly data 12 of its monthly
data and so on and I turned it into a
factor because I want to use it in a
categorical way for some of my graphs so
I just add in another feature picture
called period here and that's it really
that's all the code I need to compute a
lot of features of my time series by the
way these slides are already on my
website I'll give you a link to the
website later if you want to grab the
slides and my website is all done in
blog down the slides of areas markdown
slides on my github so you can look at
it that way as well
and so here is some of the distribution
of the features for the three thousand
and three time series it's my large
number of monthly data sum quarterly
data some annual data the seasonality
that this is a kernel density plot of
seasonality for the data so you can see
that it's very varied from 0 up to 1
with a spike at 0 because it's all a non
seasonal data so a time series that has
no seasonality looks like that time
series which has a lot of seasonality
the largest value of the feature vector
for seasonality looks like that so it
becomes almost
here's the distribution of trend a low
trend series looks like that basically
there's no trend in it it's just a flat
horizontal looking series with a lot of
noise at the other end pretty well
everything about the series is trend
that if you remove the trend there's
nothing much left that's of interest in
the data and all the way along this
horizontal axis you have things between
those two extremes this is the auto
correlation at lag one for the reason
the remainder from my STL decomposition
and you can see that again it's pretty
buried at the left hand end so the most
extreme negative auto correlation has
this sort of strange pattern and the
auto correlation is because of those
oscillations that occur occasionally and
at the other end with extreme high auto
correlation looks like that so do this
for all of my series so this is spectral
entropy so at the extreme low end that
series that have a lot of signal but not
much noise might even be the same one
that was extreme on the last graph and
at the extreme upper end that's high
entropy that means it's a lot of noise
but not much signal so they look like
that so do this for all of my series and
then I start looking at graphs of the
features against each other so every dot
in this scatter plot now is a time
series I've condensed them from long
strings of numbers which are the time
series measurements over time down to
just a vector of features and here's two
of those features plotted against each
other this is entropy on the horizontal
axis and autocorrelation function on the
vertical axis and I'm looking for
interesting patterns here do they
cluster are there outliers and so on
nothing too interesting there there's a
few weird series out here might be worth
looking at otherwise there's not a lot
of structure in this one though there is
so this is entropy on the horizontal
axis and trend on the vertical axis so
it makes sense that if entropy is very
low that means there's a lot of signal
and not much noise then trend will be
very high because that is the signal
okay so that's makes
perfectly good sense what's interesting
is this relationship between the the two
features but also this little group down
here which has low trend the high
entropy they might be worth
investigating to see what's going on
with that particular group of series can
we learn something about them so we do
this for all of the features now I'm
only in this example giving you 6
features but in practice we might use 20
or 30 different features of a time
series and look at all of the
relationships so this is a pairwise
scatterplot GG pairs from the Jiali
package an awesome function if you're
not familiar with it the G Galli package
is some sort of adds on some additional
features to ggplot2 so you all know of
course that ggplot2 was written by
Headley Wickham probably the most famous
our guy in the world you probably don't
know that his PhD supervisor was dai
cook who's in the office and next door
to me at Monash University and she's the
author of this package G galley
Hadley's PhD project was the grammar of
graphics and how to turn it into code so
ggplot2 basically is the outcome of that
PhD project so you can see here that
this the graph I showed you before and
this is another one I showed you but you
can see all of the py scatter plots for
the period which is a factor rather than
get scatter plots we're getting either
box plots along here what we're getting
histograms down this side so looking to
see what the relationship between these
things up that graph by the way is just
produced in this little bit of code we
take the features matrix or it's a data
frame that I computed a couple of slides
ago that's too far away with a bit of
code I had before produced the m3
features data frame the then I grab the
features I want to plot and I just stick
them into GPS to produce that plot
ok so we've taken a whole lot of time
series we've turned it into a vector of
features so we've reduced the dimension
enormous ly by doing that rather than
having hundreds of observations per time
series we've now got of
of in this case six features per time
series I'm going to go one more step and
do a principal component decomposition
of my six features down to only two
dimensions because it's easy to look at
them so there's my principal component
decomposition of my series and there's a
little code that I used to produce that
graph so I just use the PR comp which as
a principal components function in R I
grab the features I remove the factor
because it doesn't make any sense to put
a categorical variable into a principal
component decomposition I said I wanted
to scale it and then I just did a plot
and that explains nearly 60% of the
variation in the features that I've
computed on the data so it's a fair bit
of information in this graph and you can
see immediately that there's some
interesting stuff going on there's some
clustering along here and here and here
so the question is what are the what
does this tell me about the time series
so first of all I can do this type of
plot which tells you the direction each
of those features is pointing in this
low dimensional space so don't know
whether you can see these it's a bit
hard to see but entropy is in this
direction which means that high entropy
series are up here very noisy series low
entropy series are down here very a lot
of signal the trend is pointing in this
direction seasonality is pointing down
this way down the graph so down here
we've got high highly seasonal series
and at the top of got series with no
seasonality and so on if I now color
code them yeah yeah yeah it's which
package is that I can't remember but
it's if you look at the I'll knock down
document you'll see yeah but that's just
a one-liner to do that yeah if I color
code the data according to the features
you start seeing weather how the
structure is so this is all yet monthly
data in blue the quarterly data in green
and the annual data in pink so those
three groups are actually three
different frequencies of time series
okay so that's the sort of thing you can
do in terms of exploratory data analysis
you choose the features you want you can
stay in the high dimensional space
and do things in more huh dimensions or
you you can project down to the 2d space
or 3d if you're happy to do spinning of
these things and look at principal
components it's amazing how much you can
learn about a very large collection of
time series just by doing this one of
the reasons I started thinking about
this as I thought it might be a good way
to decide how to choose a forecasting
method so the forecast package that I've
written has I don't know about ten or
twelve different methods for forecasting
a time series and it's not always
obvious which one should be used for
which time series and with years of
experience you sort of know I this looks
like it might work with an 80s model or
this looks like I should use a ARIMA
model but how can I actually encode that
into some kind of algorithm I thought
maybe we can use features to do that so
here is so the idea was to take the
features and use them to predict which
model I should be using for each time
series so this package which is the
product of one of my PhD students called
SIA which is discovered after she named
it not everybody knows what I see it is
so a seer is a very old-fashioned word
for a prophet someone who predicts the
future so in her package which is has
tears features as a dependency you
calculate the feature so here I'm
calculating the features just on their
yearly data the annual data from the m3
competition and looking at six step
forecasting and I'm ignoring the high
frequency features and it comes back
with a vector of features for each
series so here is a data frame or a
table actually weather rose over the
series and the columns of the features
that we've computed from these things
and it's you can't see them all because
they wouldn't fit on the screen and then
there's a function which says look at
the forecast accuracy so we're trying
these models the ARIMA model ets model
random walk random walk with drift theta
method neural network and seasonal naive
and calculating the mace for each
and so it comes back saying well here's
all of my series here's the accuracy of
each of those according to the mean
absolute scaled error that's what the
Macy's mean absolute scale error and
then it tells me for each series what
the corresponding models were so the
ARIMA model that I chose here was this
one the ARIMA model that it chose for
this series was this one and so on and
here are the ets models so it's not
using features it's just saying well
here's my set of models and here's my
data let's have a look to see how which
models produce the best forecasts and
then you put these things together we've
now got a set of features and we've got
we know something about which models
work we can build an algorithm to say to
predict the model that should be used
for each series and so that's what she
went on to do I won't show you the rest
of the code we call it forms which
stands for feature based forecast model
selection and we trained a random forest
using the feature inputs and the labels
are taken from which is the best model
for each series and then we tried to be
able to use that random forest to
predict for a new series that I haven't
seen before which model should it used
we actually augmented the training data
substantially by doing lots of
simulations we entered the M for
competition with this algorithm this is
the I had two entries one with one
student or one with a different student
so with this first student we entered it
we trained it on all of the data we had
access to from previous competitions and
we tried it out didn't do so well we
came about middle of the pack was about
50 people entered I wasn't surprised
because we're trying to use one model to
predict a series and in forecasting it's
very well known that combinations work
better than single models in fact in all
of machine learning ensembles work
better than trying to use just one thing
so that was the reason I we put in a
second submission we wanted to know well
if we could choose just one model how
what's the best we could do if we could
choose a weighted combination a weighted
average of models
the best we could do so the other
algorithm is called former fork feature
based forecast model averaging in this
case we used XG boosts with feature
inputs and labels equal to the best
performing method on the test set but
rather than try to build a good
classifier which we actually don't care
about the classification we care about
forecasting so rather than try to build
a good classifier we made the
optimization criterion forecast accuracy
and the nice thing about XG boosters you
can change the optimization criterion
and make it whatever you like so we did
and then we for the fitted XG boost the
probability of each model being best was
used to construct a model weight and
then we just average did a weighted
average of all the forecasts from all
the models and so if our models not good
for a series the XT boost algorithm
should give it a low weight and so it
doesn't get to make much have much
effect on the overall forecast so we put
this into the m forecast competition as
well we came second which I was very
excited about never won never won a big
competition before so so the results of
that have just come out in fact the
paper only got released today the
results were announced about three or
four days ago so that's pretty cool
eventually we'll have this so that so as
I said this one is in the C R package
already this algorithm is not yet you
know packaged but there's a bit of code
on github and we'll turn it into a
package before long okay here we go
so I've actually got two talks that I'm
gonna do and I'm not gonna do all of
this one I want to do some of this one
but then I was talking to Jarrod
afterward that before and we thought you
might be interested in the thing I'm
working on mostly at the moment which is
a successor to the forecast package so
let me tell you a little bit about I do
this next section and then I might
switch so a little bit of work for Yahoo
on trying to identify unusual series in
a large collection so they have tens of
thousands
fact they have millions but they gave us
tens of thousands of time-series
collected of one-hour intervals over a
couple of months and these were server
metrics CPU usage and paging views and
memory and things like that
and they were trying to identify weird
stuff because they've there's too many
servers for their engineers to actually
look at everything so they wanted to be
able to have an algorithm to point the
engineers to where they should look to
see is there a problem wasn't the
algorithm wasn't gonna say there is a
problem it's just pay engineers you
should go and look at these servers
because they're behaving a little
strangely so we're still a human making
the decision about whether something was
going wrong but it was sort of guiding
the process so this is the sort of data
that we they gave us for commercial
confidentiality reasons I've chopped off
the vertical axis don't know that it
would have meant anything to you anyway
but they didn't want you to see that so
you know strange seasonality zand level
shifts and jumps and so on there's
another set and there's another set
sometimes with weird spikes in them so
we've got thousands tens of thousands of
these things so we've produced computed
a lot of features all sorts of things we
looked at the series and just sort of
tried to guess what features might
capture the stuff we see there if
there's spikes so we have a we have a
measure of spike enos if there's sort of
periods where there's a lot of variation
and then other periods where there's not
much we have a measure for and that sort
of thing the thing is the features had
to be done very fast I couldn't have a
feature that was going to take a while
to compute because this is going to be
in real time so we tried to come up with
features that were fairly simple to
compute relatively efficient but still
meaningful so there's the code that I
use for that so it's again just using
the T as features package the anomalous
package is is actually an old package of
mine that I no longer doing any work on
but it has some nice data sets in it so
I'm just bloating it here simply for the
data I put all this together into a big
matrix of time series in here and then I
run TS features on that matrix
so last the last example had a list so
tears features will either have a list
or it'll have a matrix if they're all
the same lengthy mothers will pass it as
a matrix if they're all different
lengths you leave the passive as a list
and then we select the features we want
to use and we do the same trick we do a
principal component decomposition so
there's a principal component
decomposition of a few thousand of the
Yahoo time series and remember the
interesting thing here is they want to
know where their engineers should look
so they're looking for weird things
anything that's a bit unusual so if you
look at this set of data you can see
there's some weird stuff down here
something going on with those two series
that are very different from all the
other ones this one's a bit strange and
so on maybe this one out here so we need
to there's the graph which shows you the
direction she probably can't see so I'll
just move on so we need to find a way to
measure what is weird we have this
scatterplot of time series we want to
say well which one is the one is the
most weird so we need sort of a to rank
the points based on weirdness so we fit
our bivariate kernel density estimate to
the data which basically finds the
regions where there's lots of time
series and the regions where there's not
very many and we rank them so the ones
that are furthest away from other series
will get high rank and the ones that
have lots of lots of time series around
them will get a very low rank and we
won't won't have to look at them so if
you do that here's the same graph that
I've now colored us by the hunt the
density so the points that are in the
highest density so the one percent
highest densities are in the red region
we don't care about those they're normal
the 50% region the orange region we
don't really care about them either
fifty percent of the observations are in
that region they've got us more around
them than than most the yellow region is
the 99% region and we're actually
interested in the extremely weird ones
I'm not even the 1% ones but I've just
highlighted here the top five and so for
their engineers they wanted to be able
to know where to look so we give them a
list this is the weirdest series this is
a second wieder series this is the
we're this series and whatever time
they've got they just work through the
list and then when more data comes along
it all gets recomputed maybe some other
server that's looking strange and they
need to go and look at that one so this
this is I really like this type of graph
because it's a way of plot doing a
scatter plot with a very large number of
observations with lots of over plotting
but you still see the structure because
of the coloring of the of the points so
you can do this in the HDR CDA package
just one of my packages one not such was
not so well known as some of the others
and the the code for doing that it's
just HDR scatter plot so it's very easy
you just give it to you give it an X and
you give it a Y vector and you say give
me an HDR scatter plot and it comes back
like this really useful one other
package that another student of mine is
working on is called stray which
basically is another way of finding
weird observations in a scatter plot and
so it it uses a different method that
uses extreme value theory to try to find
what's farthest away from the others to
far away from the others to be coming
from the same distribution and so it
comes back with a list you just say find
the outliers and you give up the matrix
and it'll just give you back a list of
the things that it thinks are outliers
this is the modification of another
algorithm which is some reasonably
widely used now in cran called HD
outliers I'll just skip that okay let me
just go to the packages so I've to
mentioned all of them most of these not
all of them so some of them are on cran
HDR CDA and
em come for the in competition data but
most of them aren't just on github at
the moment because they're new this is
all new stuff I'm working on I have
haven't yet got to the point where I'm
happy to put them on cran and let them
loose but there's some there's some of
the code and the different github sites
are either me or my students this is one
student and this is another student okay
and there's some of the people that have
worked on this stuff with me so I'm
gonna maybe I'll just take a couple of
what are we going for time let's take a
couple of minutes of questions and then
I'll switch to the other
well that's I'm in @xj boost so I think
what we probably need to do is to look
at which features were doing most of the
work we had we haven't done this at all
yet but analyze the what's going on
under the hood there and when it's
choosing the various models based on a
vector of features to see if we can
understand a little bit better why it's
choosing what it's doing and possibly
also look at some other features that we
haven't used to tweak it but I don't
want to do that until I actually
understand why it's doing what it's
doing now my next reboost is a bit of a
black boss box like random forests are
you throw in information and it comes
out with something new orders why did it
do that so when I actually try to unpack
that a little bit and hopefully improve
the algorithm as a result
my guess is that the micro stuff is on a
much finer scale than the macro stuff
yeah so I have come across that in in
the electricity industry where you need
to take into account you know demography
and population and GDP but you're trying
to model half-hourly data which is
electricity demand what we did there was
we actually built a model for quarterly
demand as a function of these other
exhaustion as variables that are sort of
macro state variables and then we
adjusted our half-hourly data based on
the quarterly the aggregate demand and
then we built a model on the half Ally
data which is sort of removed the effect
of the of those macro variables and then
we put it back in when we forecast and
that worked pretty well because you
separate out the macro stuff which is
happening on a long time scale quarterly
or annually from the Micro stuff which
is often happening on a very fast time
scale
yeah good questions so first question
the in the the competition data it's all
annual monthly quarterly son in their
footing for competition some early and
weekly and daily but not heaps and
attends to be data that has some
seasonality and trend in it
so they basically chose the features
because we thought they would work and
we tested a lot of features on the M 1
and M 3 data which was what was
available to us to see whether a did
give us useful information and then
apply it up to the enforce it was a lot
of trial and error and a lot of years of
experience of you know what why would I
choose this model over this model and
would I'd sit down with my student and
I'd say well I would choose an ARIMA
model here because of the data looks
stationary and an athiest model doesn't
look stationary so how can we code that
and we'd say well let's let's have a
statistic that measures the quality of
the stationerity or non-stationarity so
we'd use a unit root test or something
like that so it was very much thinking
through what goes through my head when
I'm deciding which model to use and
somehow trying to code those features
ideally of course you want to automate
that process as well and obviously yeah
we could try using auto encoders or
something but we've not gone that route
at all we just thought let's see if we
can document years of experience and
then try to improve it after we've got
that down second question about
multivariate stuff multivariate models
are extremely highly parameterised if
you have a var model for example a Vic
regression and you've got four series
it's very low dimensional your
coefficients are have 16 coefficients in
them each so it becomes very quickly
becomes extremely highly parameterised
and therefore over fitted and if you
look at the forecasting quality even if
the series of related to each other and
so in theory you should be able to get
better forecast by modeling those
relationships the VARs that you fit that
do model relationships forecast worse
than if you just ignore them all the
relationships and just do univariate
forecasting so my approach has been well
let's just concentrate on getting good
univariate forecasting and because a
forecast better and that's what I care
about not so much about the
relationships less they're helpful and
then more recently I've been working on
reconciliation methods which do try and
after doing the univariate for castings
they say well what's left if you look at
the correlations within the errors is
there anything left or that I can use
and then we use that information and
that's been quite good because you're
building on top of the univariate
forecast rather than trying to build
some massive model that's actually have
a parameterised I'll take one more then
I want to actually have time to do my
other bit because I think you'll like it
and if I just keep having questions will
not get there yes you know so the
approach that one was a data scientist
from uber called Slovak smile and he was
using some combination of a recurrent
neural network well possibly it was a
convolutional not sure some kind of
neural network with exponential waiting
so it was combining a statistical
approach exponentially weighted which is
like exponential smoothing with a
machine learning approach which is sort
of similar to us where we're combining
some statistics with some wish
and they I think the top few methods all
had some combination of statistics and
machine learning in very different ways
but trying to use them in a sort of a
clever way rather than just throwing
some big algorithm at the series to pick
them and people did put in a put in
entries where they did that that would
build Els TM or something on these
series in it and they didn't do very
well at all are in the bottom quarter of
that of the list of entrance but the
plate I Twitter the matter today the
paper that's on the m4 so if you follow
me on Twitter
Rob J Holman in the last couple of
tweets is a link to the paper okay
let me um let me switch and just briefly
because I know that we're running out of
time here I wanted to tell you about
this work so the forecast package has
been around for a while it's been around
since before 2003 and when it was just
my functions that are used in consulting
it's slowly grown over the years there's
now about a hundred thousand package
downloads per month so it's about a
million users I think and I have some
ideas to make major changes but I don't
want to a million angry people emailing
me so I thought well let's leave that as
it is people can use it and whatever
I'll keep maintaining it to make sure it
keeps working that I'm gonna put some
effort into something else that because
it doesn't actually do a few things very
well one of the things that doesn't do
is it doesn't integrate with tidy burst
packages very well or yeah other data
table or anything like that it's just
it's designed oh the second blood point
there is a little misleading what I want
to do is design something for
forecasting lots of series the forecast
package is designed for forecasting
individual series and as in the question
we had a couple ago it I doesn't it
really doesn't work it's not designed to
work for multiple time series the
interface is pretty inconsistent
sometimes there's forming
sometimes there's not sometimes there's
x-ray garments for exhaustion as
variables and that's confusing I'd
rather do something with distribution
forecasting rather than just points in
intervals and compute the point in
interval forecast later because it's
more general and it means you can do a
lot more interesting stuff and so on if
you got hourly data or weekly data or
even daily data that forecast packages
just doesn't do it very well because
it's using TS objects and tier subjects
are highly constrained to have mean that
the time index is in a decimal what's
new miracle so if you've got half hourly
data and you look at the time index
sentence you find out that you're at
time one point zero seven nine three to
one half hour and what day is that
you notice and it's hard to work out so
we I thought let's try and do something
different so let me show you well just
because I haven't a lot of time I just
show you one example this one here so
this is a typical time series which is
more than just one set of numbers so
this is prison populations in Australia
so this is the state of Australia a
cities the smallest state this is of
territory actually but we'll call it a
state for now this is the gender this is
what legal status there's two legal
statuses and this is the court this is
the date that comes straight out of the
CSV file that the client provided me
with and that happens to be the first
date of the quarter first day of the
quarter and this is the number of
prisoners that correspond to that
combination yeah Australia does have a
few more prisoners than that but this is
in the very smallest territory with the
highest socioeconomic status so there's
not very many prisoners of in in the
Australian Capital Territory so to turn
that into something that that's useful
for the new package we first of all take
the time index and turn it into a year
or in this case a year quarter so you
can use lubricate functions here Libra
day doesn't have a year quarter function
so we provide it and then we remove the
T column so the T column was this column
which when it were you read it in from
CSV that just took turned it into a date
but it's the first date of the quarter
but it's actually we're not really this
was quarterly data so the other dates
don't mean anything so we turn it into
just quarters like this and then we turn
it into a Sybil which stands for time
series table and the index is the the
time index here the keys the factors in
this case these three factors and
everything else is a measurement a time
series in this case we've just got one
count then if I say now I want to fit an
80s model to the present data it fits
an ETS model to every combination of the
factors so you come back immediately
with this table which has for every
combination of these three factors that
gives you the data set that is the
subsets corresponding to those three the
combination of those three factors and a
model okay so very quickly you can have
a whole table full of models we call
this a Mable which stands for model
table and if you want to do forecasting
you just apply the forecast object
forecast function to that object and it
will forecast all of the models
simultaneously so here's it just adds
another column okay so it's exactly the
same structure it just adds another
column we call this a fable which stands
for forecast table and the package is
also called fable for the two reasons
one is because we're forecasting tables
and the second reason is because a fable
is never true but it tells you something
important about reality and that's what
a forecast is it's not the truth but it
tells you something important about the
reality and notice that the forecast is
represented as a distribution so this is
distributed as normal and there's eight
steps ahead if you want to actually look
at those forecasts you just know I
haven't got it sorry let me show you one
where I have got it there's one where I
have got it you just apply the summary
to the to the forecast object and it'll
summarize them as these usual format
with an index with a mean with a
division interval with a 95% interval so
it's going to make it a lot easier to
work with large collections of time
series that are related and you want to
forecast them all simultaneously and
they come in and your data is already in
a data frame or in a table it'll just
work okay that's probably enough just I
wanted to briefly mention it so this two
packages so far there's the Sybil
package which handles time series
Tibbals and there's the Fable package
which handles forecasting tables and
there's another couple that I haven't
mentioned here that we're going to put
in together into this collection of
packages which we are calling tidy verts
tidy version of time series which is a
little bit of a joke with Hadley because
Hadley produced a package called for
cats which is always confused with the
forecast package so I thought well I'll
produce tidy verts tidy version of time
series and this is joint work with dye
who's had Lee's PhD supervisor and my
office colleague and our two students
who are two of the most awesome
programmers I've ever worked with they
are brilliant so IRA's working on Sybil
and Mitch's working on fable figured a
tidy verse dog you can see the packages
it will just redirect to github and
there's my blog where I will provide
some more information as we progress
we're having to have something that sort
of reasonably complete by the end of the
year and probably on cran thank you
[Applause]
yeah so if you had geographical data as
well that would be keys so just as in
this example here so this is a very
simple case where we had geography here
we have state that's a geographical
variable but you could have state and
regions and zones and cities and so on
and you can do all of that they will be
geographical factors that'll be nested
one inside the other and the package is
set up for nesting so that you can have
hierarchies of geography or hierarchies
of products if you're doing
manufacturing or whatever you can have
you can have any keys you like here as
many as you like including whatever
geographical factors you think are
important for your application yeah
so eventually we'll have pretty well
everything that's in the forecast
package at the moment weaving with
implemented ETS and a reamer and linear
models we're working our way through the
list basically yeah and at the moment
it's basically acting as a front end to
the forecast package and us calling
those functions but eventually we will
pull all the hint of the fable package
as well and and separate them and I'm
not planning on on deprecating the
forecast package I'm just planning on
doing maintenance releases instead
what what do you mean by liars in done
in the neural net yeah yeah it just does
a single single hidden Maya
um was two reasons one is I just write
the function to show my students how you
could do neural network order
regressions that was the only purpose
for and then I thought well I might as
well put in the package somebody might
use it but secondly neural nets for
individual time series are generally not
very useful because there's not enough
data even in a relatively long series to
build a complicated in your honor you're
less worked well in the deep learning
type of neural net on a huge collection
so Amazon uses a for forecasting but
they're fitting a deep Learning Network
for their entire product catalog and so
they look they're learning from similar
products or said with products were
similar metadata but if you try to fit a
neural net to one univariate time series
it's not going to work very long so it's
more just a demonstration of how to
think about think about it if you wanted
to do it but that's not a see I never
considered it a serious function
um well that's one of the reasons I will
always produce prediction intervals by
default is that if you don't people
start to believe the forecast
and of course they're wrong but
hopefully they're useful and the
prediction intervals tells you how
useful they are and so that was and and
so the plotting will always produce
prediction intervals unless you do some
work to get rid of it and that's about
managing people's expectations and also
informing them about uncertainty
hopefully the fable name will also help
get the idea across that a forecasters
not a prophecy it's it's not an Oracle
it's a you know informed mathematical
statement about the future
you're the wreck on TV show
now it's only using Tibbles and you'll
have to convert your data table to
tables well it works with data frames
but it doesn't work directly with data
tables yeah we're simply because we
wanted to integrate it in with deep wire
and with with the tiny verse stuff and
largely because I do I teach forecasting
and my students are learning all the
tidy verse stuff in their other classes
and I thought it would be a whole lot
easier for them if they could use the
forecast package in the same way but I
mean there's obviously a data table as a
lot faster when you have very very large
collections of data and someone else
will have to write that package
[Applause]